I like a man who knows their water when
you see those bottles that cost like $6
for water I'm insulted I bought a water
on the airplane once it was time : I
want to be beautiful after this you have
in the Beverly Hills I don't think I'm
allowed bad this bottle is really pretty
though it's probably LA tap water that
they just bought it's Beverly Hills a
place known for water like I don't think
it is cheers Cheers
it's really really clean and I feel like
it has no aftertaste yeah it tastes like
water tastes like tap water it's like
I'm drinking nothing will get the job
done but I'm not gonna pay more than a
dollar for it from whale we're getting
international up in here it's crazy to
think that they like ship water over
water it's a little bit more full I'm
making this [ __ ] up and I'm it kind of
fits that one's a bite it's Christmas is
crisper I mean it's just taste water
water or like after a marathon is like
really hydrate you oh it's mineral water
natural mineral water Rome there um look
at that there's like 20 greens in this
thing this is not just water
is it healthy water I like this I like
this water tastes like chalk in my mouth
this is like my tap water I mean you
have great tap water then I'm definitely
tasting some like elements it's got a
bad alike after days in the back in the
mouth maybe this is just like ancient
water tastes kind of old yeah out of the
aqueducts
what is it I mean it's something that I
would love to have enough fight also can
you carry it like out in public but like
the cops pull you over sorry I'm just
drinking water in the corner why does
the cork have a condom on it this is the
dumbest thing I really know my life same
water it's all the same I can't deal
with this tastes like tap water
I think the coating of the bottle might
affect the taste yeah this is gross so
water was nasty I need y'all to know
that I feels pretty good I think this is
the only one that actually has like some
flavor to it I think I would just rather
keep it to ward off evil spirits yeah
it's kind of [ __ ] I feel like all
these expensive waters is literally just
the bottle I'm disappointed in expensive
water company it just tastes like a
regular ass water drink lots of water
kids and makes it grow fast and pee a
lot this is a disgrace net worth is dry